لقد حان الوقت لأن يرى مجلس أوروبا
أن هذا يفهمه ويتفاعل
[الموسيقى
] ونعلم جميعًا أن الإسلاموفوبيا
آخذة في الارتفاع في أوروبا ، أعني على جميع المستويات أن
هذا ليس فقط النازيين الجدد الذين
يهاجمون المسلمين الذين رأينا ذلك في
وسائل الإعلام التي رأيناها في صانعي السياسات يستخدمونها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كنت أعطي مثالاً أثناء
المناظرة
امرأة محجبة تسير في الشوارع
فقط تهتم بعملك ويمكن أن
يكون لديك أشخاص تعرفهم ينادونك
بأسمائهم ويهينونك  وتقويض
كرامتك وأحيانًا إلى حد
الاعتداء والاعتداء الجسدي الوحشي
على
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما نحتاج إليه هو الإرادة السياسية
للانتقال فعليًا من النظرية إلى الممارسة
للتأكد من
أن المسلمين هم من اليهود
في أي دين
تعتقد أنك تنتمي إليه ،
يجب أن تكون قادرًا على عيش حياة كريمة
في
أوروبا وهذا شيء لا يمكن
قبوله في أي مجتمع ديمقراطي
نحتاج إلى أن نكون  قادر على حماية
حقوق الناس ويجب أن نطلب من
الجمعية البرلمانية لمجلس أوروبا بذل
كل ما في وسعها لحماية
والتأكد من احترام حقوق الناس
بغض النظر عن دينهم بغض
النظر عن جنسهم بغض النظر عن
أصلهم أو أي خلفية لديهم